hey youtubers is charlie so there's a
new teaser for star wars the force
awakens the quality isn't great but we
do get a glimpse of Lupita's character
mas que nada so see if you can spot her
and then we'll talk about her a little
bit heroes villains amazing new
creatures incredible adventure
possibilities the what wins with these
elements together into one big story the
ultimate choice between good and evil
installment the paper called Jedi the
Jedi or Ancient Order dedicated to
protecting the galaxy did I can tuck
into the mystical energy field shared by
all living things they call it the flux
Rock side to that our consulting to the
winter
enjoy that I could change your destiny
forever the heroes on this epic
adventure use the poster making a choice
this data will be lost in the dark side
forever and it all starts with that
first step into the unknown maybe a
whole lot is that way you decide you're
going on an adventure and embrace your
own destiny
this one blue squad take my lead I'm on
it
hold on
Wow so just in case you missed it this
is what her character is supposed to
look like JJ Abrams said that there's
something very special about her eyes
and they make it sound like there's an
actual power like if you look at the
actual character description in the
interview that he did he says I had some
specific ideas about how she would work
and what she would do I had this pitch
about these goggles that she wore her
eyes are an important aspect of the
character and you'll see how it plays
out now because her character's supposed
to be a thousand years old which is
older than Yoda people are taking this
to mean that she does have some sort of
special power whether or not she's
force-sensitive we have no idea but she
is kind of a Yoda type character someone
who imparts ancient knowledge and serves
as something of a guide before they meet
Luke Skywalker the planet that her
pirate castle is on is supposed to be
called taco Dada now as of this battle
in the movie like it looks like there's
a big battle with the first order I
don't think the characters have met Luke
Skywalker yet I think that she's a stop
on the way to Luke Skywalker who kind of
seems more like a Ben Kenobi in this
film but if you guys remember the
previous teasers and trailers that
they've posted she talks about
recognizing the characters I've seen
those eyes before for the most part I
think that's just meant to thematically
linked the characters to the original
trilogy characters like oh these
characters look like some of the
characters from these other films but it
would be really cool if Lupita does
actually have special powers like she's
not just a regular alien but even if
she's not for sensitive if you were to
live for a thousand years like Yoda for
instance if you're looking on 900 years
you would be incredibly wise in
knowledge is power too that's why right
now I'm thinking of Andy's circuses
character is kind of like the evil
mirror of maz kanata's character because
he's also very long-lived very powerful
very big in someone who sounds like he
predates Emperor Palpatine and in no I
do not in any way think that he is Darth
Jar Jar I'm not even gonna touch that
theory I think it's completely hot
garbage but it is funny as a headline
but look at ma's kannada here and let me
know in the comments do you think that
she actually does have some sort of
special powers do you think she's
force-sensitive you usually people
having powers in the Star Wars universe
means that they're force-sensitive there
are people that use the force in
different types of ways like you have
four switches but usually you either
have tech based powers or your force
sensitive in some way so let me know
what you think about her in the comment
below and just for fun who do you think
is more beautiful Lupita in real life or
captain phasma in her chrome trooper
armor there are a lot of goddamn
beautiful people in this movie in and
out of costume the other part of this
clip is just Poe Dameron with one of the
female x-wing pilots you might recognize
her as jessica henrik who plays Nymeria
sand on Game of Thrones that's right one
of the x-wing pilots is a sand snakes
somehow that just feels so appropriate
and we also see nian nub the actor who
played him confirmed that he's back
doing work on this so this is actually
that character from the cannon and if
you guys didn't know Stephen Colbert
actually just did this big event with JJ
Abrams it was called Stephen Colbert vs
JJ Abrams nerd-off they were just having
like this fun sit-down conversation so
I'm gonna play a clip here but the
interesting thing is is that Abram said
that he finished scoring the movie like
he finished a big cut of the movie at
two-thirty a.m. the night before he flew
out to do this Stephen Colbert thing so
here's the clip the audio isn't super
great but it is really fun to listen to
him talk about the film I do feel like I
it's a religion without God it's that we
are all connected with an energy force
and I just that has 11 year old it's not
like it makes sense it felt like I think
what I love about Star Wars was it I
remember feeling like if there is this
thing that can be harnessed that can
thicken working with you that I think
everyone leaving that theater felt like
if I really needed you I'd like to
believe I can harness that power and it
was it was a non-denominational you know
powerful idea that I was very important
to us in this bill to bring back and
allow it to be a little bit of magic and
a little bit
that helped be something at the center
but what's happening tonight is we have
a new episode of the walking dead i'll
post it after it airs so be sure to
subscribe to get everything I'm also
going to be doing more jessica jones in
Game of Thrones tomorrow white guys wait
for everything to post you can click
here for my Star Wars Episode 7 playlist
with like all the big trailers that I've
been posting and you can click here for
my Jessica Jones episode playlist
hopefully you guys been watching it's
been an awesome series so far thank you
so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight me
me me me